Love your new show,
"The Endgame."
(Ryan laughs)
Is it true that you would take your work home with you?
You're talking about the knives, aren't you?
Uh-huh.
(laughs) So I'm a big fat chicken, just FYI.
Like when these people told me
that they wanted me to play an FBI agent,
I was like, do they?
I can't fight, I don't know how fight, I can't,
I can't fight.
You wouldn't know that watching that.
Well, thank you very much.
And so my door in the apartment that I'm staying in
has this problem, it doesn't always close all the way.
And I know this, I know this.
And the first time it happened, I called the super
and had him walk through the apartment with me
to make sure nobody was,
you know, you gotta check under the bed.
Like, where's the murderer, where's the serial killer?
You know how this goes?
We're women, we know.
Yes.
So the second time it happened, I was like,
I am Val Turner, I am Agent Val Turner.
Whoever's in here is about to get it, right?
Yes!
So I open the door and I'm like,
in the back of my mind, I know there's no serial killer,
but just in case, just in case, right?
So I got two knives and I had 'em
and I was like, what would Val Turner...
It's a wonder I did not stab myself,
and somebody found me bleeding to death.
'Cause I'd go through the whole apartment,
and I'm like, stab,
and I'm opening the doors, and I was like.
And when I was all done and realized
there was no serial killer hiding in my apartment,
I was like, I have to be the dumbest human being.
'Cause what would I have done?
What would Sterling do?
Did you ever pull a knife on him?
(laughs) No, no.
But he does love to scare me, like it's his favorite thing.
Really?
Yes, and it's horrible.
'Cause he's good at it.
He could win seven Emmys and it would not touch the joy
of seeing the terror on his wife's face.
And he'll record it.
Now I saw on Instagram
that you were making a cornbread recipe.
Yes.
But there was a missing ingredient.
I'm a big corn casserole freak.
So was it white, like white cornmeal?
It was white cornmeal.
Not yellow cornmeal.
Not yellow, yes.
So there's this whole thing in LA.
I can't find the white cornmeal,
because in LA, most people use yellow cornmeal
for like the tortillas and all of the different,
the tamales and stuff like that,
you don't usually use white cornmeal.
So I was on this hunt during the pandemic,
and it was like, why am I in these streets
trying to find some?
And I was like, yellow cornmeal will be fine.
So now I had this yellow dressing and my whole family,
it was like, why are you trying to poison your children?
No one's gonna survive Thanksgiving,
'cause Ryan has the nasty yellow dressing.
(upbeat bright music)